I remember the first day at the fruit
fly lab uh I thought that the smell was
really really bad
scientists started using model organisms
and research hundreds of years ago
you've heard of the expression being a
guinea pig right and that was because
guinea pigs were initially used in labs
to study deficiencies in vitamin C and
some researchers even believed that the
Asian Greeks used animals in performing
experiments and doing research so this
idea of model organisms is not a new one
it has been around for hundreds of years
and it has tremendously helped
scientists in understanding biology if
you're studying biology there's a
there's a big chance you're going to use
model organisms when you go to work in a
lab or to do research whenever we have a
hypothesis in biology most of the time
we need to test it in a living organism
so that could be fruit flies that could
be fish that could be plants any living
organism can serve as a model organism
and while these animals or plants Etc
are complex they're a little bit more
simple than a human biology we are
talking about specific species that have
been at some point introduced into the
lab and most of the time their genome
has been sequenced and scientists has
been really studying uh these organisms
technically every organism can be a
model organism but what makes a good
model organism most of the time it is
the ease of studying that model organism
in the lab and a good model organism is
subjective to your own research and to
your own question so a good model
organism for you would be one that would
allow you to answer your specific
scientific question again if we go back
to the example of fruit flies we can
easily raise them in the lab we can grow
them by millions they have few
chromosomes with much fewer genes than
the human genome so it's really easy to
understand interaction between these
genes some other researchers would be
studying
neurogenesis for example and to study
neurogenesis scientists like to use C
elegans the worms see Elegance as a
model organism the advantage of a c
elegans worm is that it's transparent
and it has
very few neurons so scientists can
actually look at a worm under the
microscope and track a single neuron so
that makes it a good model organism for
that particular question you choose a
particular model organism to answer a
specific question and then sometimes you
have to choose another model organism
more complex or even sometimes more
simple to answer additional questions
that are based on your research but
model organisms like everything else in
life have some limitations for example
when you're studying when you're doing
your research in mice mice are expensive
so you cannot really do what I was doing
and dissecting hundreds of brains
mice have a gestation time that is a
little bit longer than fruit flies or c
elegans for example like a fruit fly
lifespan is only 50 days right whereas a
mouse have a lifespan is about of about
three years so you can imagine that if
you're studying aging you would want to
study it in a fruit fly because it has a
shorter lifespan but now if you wanted
to answer more complex question well you
have to go the three years and now you
have to use a mouse to do your research
another major limitation of model
organisms is for scientists to
understand that findings among organisms
do not necessarily always translate to
human diseases or to human biology you
take a lot of the research that has been
done recently on developing vaccines
against Alzheimer's that work very well
in mice but that do not give the same
effect in humans and do not work for
that particular for that particular case
yes there is an ethical question around
using model organisms and biological
research the ethical problem with with
using animals in medical research is
really to making sure that you know
we're using them
sparsely and we're making sure that
we're only using animals when it is
essential that we are using lower model
organisms when possible to answer
certain questions rather than you know
like sacrificing mice and you can even
imagine you know like even higher model
organisms
like monkeys or apes and when you're
studying mice for example you have to
write specific protocols that get
approved by ethical comedies to make
sure that your use of animals in this
particular case is Justified it is not
only about sacrificing the animal it's
how you use your animal in your research
so for example when you're working with
mice you cannot put more than a certain
number of mice in a particular cage when
you're doing experiments you have to do
your best to limit their suffering you
have to anesthetize them model organisms
have been crucial in helping us
understand biology like we understand it
today and it is important to acknowledge
that while the ethical questions about
sacrificing animals is extremely
relevant and while some research some
biological research can be done without
using animal models for example in cells
scientists
the advantage that model organisms
bringing is that complexity and the
interaction between systems for example
or the interaction between different
cells I was studying Alzheimer's and the
fruit fly and that was a great model
organism because I was expressing my
human gene that caused the front the fly
to develop symptoms similar to
Alzheimer's and that was in the nervous
system that I was studying the
interaction of immune cells with these
nervous system cells right so could I
have studied this question and this
problem in cell cultures
probably but it cell culture would never
be able to replicate the complexity and
that a whole
organism can bring so model organisms
give you
at the same time a simplified version of
let's say human biology but also a model
or a system that is complex enough where
you could study the interactions between
different genes or between different
proteins or between
RNA and proteins it is the platform that
we use to really confirm and our
hypotheses and study them and get data
to move them forward and ask more
questions
foreign
[Music]